The first choice is true. Objects definitely get dimmer the further they are
from a light source. The number of photons hitting a surface drops off
proportional to the square of the distance from the light. The second choice is
false. There's no reason that objects wouldn't have colors. Well, maybe if all
the objects in the closet were gray, but that's not a fair assumption. The third
choice is also false. Even though you're at the light source's location, the
objects can receive different amounts of photons, depending on their distance
from and angle to the light. The fourth choice is true. This is the main point
of this question. What the light sees, by definition, is not in shadow. We'll
use this fact later in the course to generate shadows on objects.